seize des polémiques inutiles de la
division de la nation en plus le point
technique qui faisait problème c'est en
effet qu'une partie des dons étaient
défiscaliser les plus grands donateurs
refusent en tout cas voilà ne veulent
pas que ça soit défiscaliser de ce sera
des dons on est donc là je vois plus où
est la polémique où elle se situe sinon
ben que certains on a intérêt au soir
pour rester dans la lumière soit pour
gratter quelques voix alors oui voilà
voulait.après après la polémique ce qui
ce que disent ceux qui se plaignent ils
disent voilà on a réussi à mettre autant
d'argent voilà sur la table en très peu
de temps
est-ce qu'on n'aurait pas pu l'utiliser
aussi d'autrefois mais voilà un mais
juste juste il faut rappeler que la
france est un pays très très heureux
distributif donc c'est pas vrai que il
se passe rien pendant l'année iliad et
on perd énormément d'impôts et ses
impôts sont redistribuées il pourrait
l'être autrement il pourrait l'être plus
mais c'est pas vrai qu'on ne se soucie
que des pierres je vois des gens riches
mais chacun veut de son argent quand
même moi je les applaudit des deux mains
plutôt que de critiquer cc c'est
scandaleux de les critiquer alors une
fois et ils font ce qu'ils veulent
merci d'avoir participé et d'aider à la
reconstruction de notre dame
voilà mes oeufs lee mission poyer encore
une fois si la redistribution des impôts
se fait bien sûr fait mal et qui était
assez pâle ce ne sont pas des hommes
politiques sont déjà qu'il faut nous
voilà des affaires comme on dit qu'ils
font du business qui réussissent bravo
on a besoin de gens qui réussissent et
surtout a besoin de gens généreux et
dans ce cas là ils sont généreux donc
merci andré bercoff bon je voudrais
juste revenir sur quelque chose par
rapport à vraiment on a salué les
pompiers
mais il faut que ce soit une leçon
extraordinaire pour ce qui se passera
france parce qu'il faut pas oublier on
ne l'a pas du tout parlé que les
pompiers se font caillasser les seuils
voiture non ça c'est un autre débat
il y en a il il l'a dit un peu mais je
veux dire que ce soit leçon pour tout le
monde parce qu'il est pas mixtes vont
piger meta par rapport à ça
effectivement c'est à la fois moi j'ai
dit oui vous comprenez la polémique
juste un mot je comprends la polémique
et en même temps à partir du moment où
effectivement ils disent c'est le tram
c'est notre argent personnel et nous
n'allons pas avoir des défiscalisations
dépôts ne va pas toucher les 60% qu'elle
vienne pour cent c'est un autre problème
ça ne devrait plus le même problème et
puis je vais vous dire une chose
quand on dit il n'ya pas opposer les
choses c'est que effectivement ils se
sont donné évidemment c'est une image
importante parce qu'il faut pas oublier
tout le contexte là l'évasion fiscale
les 100 milliards et c'est parce que en
même temps les mêmes personnes
ils sont sûrs dans une optimisation
fiscale totale par rapport à leur
fortune dont faut pas l'oublier mais en
même temps c'est bien qu'ils aient
financé la restauration notre dame des
mines mohamed et agathe vous avez dit
non on va savoir pourquoi j'ai dit oui
vous va savoir pourquoi
gimme oui il faut pas que ça se
transforme en haine du riche moi je n'ai
aucun problème avec ces gens qui donnent
et heureusement qu'ils sont là parce que
il contribue énormément à l'impôt ils
ont aussi des oeuvres caritatives et
sûrement font beaucoup plus que moi jy
mohamed de mon côté donc déjà merci à
eux maintenant on peut s'interroger
quand même un milliard en deux trois
jours alors qu'on nous a dit il n'ya pas
d'argent magique
il va falloir se serrer la ceinture il
va falloir faire des efforts et on dit
on n'oppose pas les choses bah moi je
vais quand même les oppose et je suis
désolé un milliard d'euros pour de la
pierre alors oui à une histoire
oui il ya un patrimoine meder les gens
qui sont à la rue est aussi une histoire
bien aussi qu'il ya patrimoine ya aussi
quelque chose
et à la fin on entend le président dira
je m'engage que dans cinq ans notre dame
traoré pour rénover alors que des
experts 10 10 10 à 15 ans il avait tenu
un engagement que je considère bien plus
important qui était celui ne plus avoir
de sdf d'ici la fin de l'année
j'aimerais qu'il commence par respecter
cet engagement avant de s'engager à dire
que notre dame sera rénové donc ça dit
aussi à mon sens la cité un peu folle
dans laquelle on vit parce que quand on
regarde ce que le sidaction a rapporté
moins de 10 millions d'euros
mais les restos du coeur les dont j'ai
regardé c'est moins de 5 millions
d'euros le téléthon 85 minutes et là en
quelques heures on a 1 milliards donc on
est en droit de se poser la question de
dans quelle société vivons nous et ce
quand on veut vraiment est-ce qu'on
pourrait pas faire autrement
est ce qu'on pourrait aller parler un
peu au delà et surtout est-ce qu'il
faudrait pas peut-être y aller vraiment
plus sur d'autres sujets donc moi je
trouve ça choquant mais encore une fois
pas de haine anti riches
merci à eux 2 des merciers eux d'exister
merci pour leurs impôts parce qu'on a
besoin d'eux en france agathe
oui la question c'est est ce que on
comprend la polémique est donc
l'indignation est donc la colère et donc
la perplexité et donc l'incompréhension
de certaines personnes qui ont ces ici
connaissent des fins de mois extrêmement
difficile le pays est plongé dans une
crise sociale sans précédent
et ces personnes là qui se
éveil le lendemain matin et qui voit que
pinault arnault fin tous les grands
groupes tous et il donne il donne aussi
efficace d'associations
on n'est pas là la question c'est pas
détester vous ce que ce qui est les dons
qui ont été fait pas du tout grand grand
merci à eux comme comme l'a très
justement répéter jimmy la question est
ce que le comprend une indignation
qu'une colère qu est ce qu un sentiment
d'injustice peut naître chez ces
personnes dans la difficulté qui luttent
maintenant depuis des mois et des mois
pour faire entendre une voix et pour
avoir une mesure significative qui va
dans leur sens dans le sens du pouvoir
d'achat dans le sens d'une meilleure
justice sociale de l'argent débloqué de
quelque part pour les aider moi je les
comprends am il promet on n'attaque pas
les généraux generation est ce qu'on
pense qu'elle dit agathe et c'est ce qui
est ressorti sur les réseaux sociaux
s'est il dit on a réussi quand même à
réunir un milliard d'euros en trois
jours c'est tout les gens ont du moins
ce que c'est notre dame
quelque chose oui mais les gens se
disent c'est notre dame et et les gens
dans la rue tous les jours pour bien
nommé madame je vous dis je vous dis ce
que j'ai vu sur les réseaux sociaux je
sais si oui moi je suis interpellé bravo
déjà sept bien se rendre générosité
vraiment on ne peut qu'applaudir après
si on ne constate pas qu'il ya un
problème c'est qu'on est hypocrite c'est
pas possible on n'a pas perdu
attends attends attends je dire il ya
des gens qui ont faim on est en pleine
crise de gilet jaune ya des gens qui
souffrent c'est normal que ça choque
donc oui je suis choqué de voir ce
paradoxe entre des gens qui ont faim qui
sont en crise et cet argent qui passe on
parlait tout à l'heure que vous disiez
talent qui donnait aux associations oui
mais il ya une baisse de moitié de dons
aux associations à cause de la réforme
de l'isf
donc je pense que c'est aussi une façon
de la réforme de la baisse de la
défiscalisation et c'est donc c'était
aussi une façon de se racheter par
rapport à cette baisse des dons qui a eu
en 2018 deuxième point je voulais dire
que on a vu aussi que les français comme
les riches donnent à partir du moment où
tout est ciblé à partir du moment où
c'est à qui on donne on va où va
l'argent tourner moralité je pense que
même dans la crise des gilet jaune parce
que c'est ce qui est sous jacent si on
cible si on dit à qui on donne pourquoi
comment là je pense qu'on va se
mobiliser une question pour vous cyril
mais bon soir j'espère que choqué parce
que je posais une question si vous
perdre
la deuxième est celle de quel journal
christine kelly sur ip dtp merci bonsoir
oui hanouna dépendantes une question
sans vous gêner vous avez lancé le cri
de la banque du coeur oui personne n'en
a parlé
qui vous a soutenu alors dirigé les
jaunes n'ont même pas regardé il ya des
artistes qui m'ont soutenu il ya de
nombreux gilet jaune qui sont qui sont
avec nous et on est en train de le
lancer là on va le lancer en juin et on
espère qu'il y aura un gros élan de
générosité parce que voilà c'est c'est
mon arme on a pensé c'est vrai qu'on a
tous pensé au bureau quand on a vu ça
mais bon après l'urgence c'est vrai que
la cité notre-dame et nous on veut pas
forcer les gens à donner mais c'est vrai
que vous voudrez que des grands groupes
puissent de tous ceux qui ont donné pour
notre gamme escada un qui vous ont
contacté un de ces groupes sur les sites
et ce qu'elle a un qui se dit pour
l'instant ce n'est pas concret je pense
que quand ce sera concret jeunes
enseignants retraités n'ont pour
l'instant on peut pas alors tombé dedans
mais l'opposant balles deux choses voilà
alors quand même de ma karim zéribi
après on écoutera nos invités
non moi pourquoi je veux pas rentrer
dans la polémique parce que je pose une
question est simple avons nous eu besoin
de notre dame de paris pour nous rendre
compte qu'ils avaient des salaires
quasiment une descente chez certains
patrons avons nous eu besoin de notre
dame de paris pour nous dire qu'il y
avait aujourd'hui des fortunes qui avait
été fait parce que le système marche sur
la tête avant nous il besoin notre dame
de paris pour nous dire qu'il y avait
des inégalités inacceptables dans notre
pays est bien au delà de avec ceux qui
avaient d'argent ne plus savoir qu'en
faire et ce qu'ils ne savaient pas
comment ça allait finir les fins de mois
remplir le frigo
la réponse est non donc la réalité c'est
que le combat de la lutte contre et
c'est gai c'est un combat qui n'a pas
tendu notre dame c'est un combat qui
doit être mené
c'est un combat qui mérite effectivement
beaucoup de force beaucoup de conviction
beaucoup de mobilisation mais là aller
chercher la polémique sur ce qui a été
je vais dire une émotion pas nationales
internationales qui a dépassé le cadre
des catholiques puisque c'est quand même
un lieu de culte mais qui est aussi un
lieu historique
un monument de qui retrace l'histoire
quasiment une civilisation de la réalité
c'est que je trouve mal placé dans le
contexte dans un temps aussi court
qu'on aille chercher notre dame de paris
pour aller poursuivre des combats qu'on
se doit de mener et qu'on se doit de
mener au delà de la séquence qu'on vient
de vivre deux qui est certaine les mêmes
depuis longtemps et continuerons de les
mener donc la réalité du problème c'est
papineau s'est passé pas ces gens là qui
bénéficient d'un système c'est le pti
thème et le système ils n'en sont pas
les créateurs ne sommes pas les
fondateurs donc moi j'en veux plus tôt à
la puissance publique
j'en veux plutôt politique j'en veux
plus tôt peut-être même j'ai envie de
dire là des collectivités qui sont
capables de sortir 5 4 millions d'euros
et des collectivités je parle pas assez
riches
un riche la fortune privée oui c'est
vrai de l'argent public et là c'est vrai
que pour des sdf pour des travailleurs
pauvres pour des retraités qui n'en peut
plus pour des gens qui dorment dans leur
voiture où il est c'est rageant public
n'a sur quoi on a du mal à le trouver
c'est ça rapidement c'est ça c'est ça la
clé c'est ça qui est la vérité sur cuir
ne vais pas me l'ont pas les combats
nous nous trompons pas de quoi là parce
que parce qu'on peut dire aussi s'il
n'avait pas donné on leur serait tombé
dessus il donne l'ordre de fait on doit
rien et après on va on va rentrer dans
un système où les gens n'ont plus rien à
perdre ce qu'ils vont dire que si on va
taper dessus